welcome back so we're talking about the divergence
the gradient and the curl these vector calculus
operations that we're going to use to describe
physical systems and partial differential
equations in the last lecture we talked about the
gradient operator and now we're going to zoom into
the divergence operator and this one is really
really useful for studying things like fluid
flows compressible or incompressible fluid
flows and a lot of other other applications
to the divergence so i'm going to jump right
in remember that this nabla or dell operator
if i write down del in two dimensions that is a
vector of partial derivatives partial partial x
and partial partial y in the second component
so it's a two component vector field the first
component is a derivative in the x direction
the second component is the derivative in the
y direction and the gradient would apply this del
operator to a scalar function f which would then
create a vector-valued function of the partial
derivatives but the divergence notice we're
taking the dot product of this vector of partials
and so we're going to take the dot product with
a vector-valued function f so if we have some
vector-valued function f we'll call it f bar
and we'll say that that has components f1 and
f2 and in general f1 would be a function of x
and y and f2 would be a function of x and y
i might drop this dependence in a little bit
then we can take the divergence of f
or the del dot f just like you would
normally do a dot product of two vectors
this is a vector and this is a vector
and so if i take sometimes we call this div for
the divergence of f and that equals del dot f
and that equals the partial partial x of f1 so
partial f1 partial x plus partial partial y of f2
plus partial f2 partial y now remember when i had
a scalar function just a single scalar function of
x and y if i took its gradient i created a vector
valued function and similarly with the divergence
if i have if i take the dot product of del with
a vector valued function the dot product of two
vectors is a scalar and so i take my vector valued
function and its divergence is a scalar valued
function this is just a scalar function which is
the sum of these two partial derivatives okay and
this is really really useful this essentially i'll
show you in pictures in a minute in some examples
this quantity here tells you how much that vector
field f this f is a vector field it tells you how
much that vector field is locally sourcing out
or sinking in kind of pulling material in or
blowing material out and if the divergence is
zero then there's no net kind of you know local
compression or compressibility of that vector
field so we'll talk about this in a little bit
i want to point out just like the gradient
operator is a linear operator the divergence
is also a linear operator so maybe i'll
just write that out very very explicitly so
div is linear
and what this means is that if i take the uh
the divergence of the sum of two vector fields f
let's call it a plus f b that equals the uh
divergence of f a plus the divergence of f b
uh and so on and so forth so you can verify this
yourself kind of just try uh try this out and
you'll see that this this definitely does add
in a linear way similarly the divergence of a
constant times f a is just that constant times
the divergence of f a and so this operator is
linear which means that the sum of solutions is
also a solution which is is kind of nice so this
we're going to use these as building blocks for
partial differential equations later and those
pdes if we build them out of these building blocks
will be linear partial differential equations
okay good so i want to give you some examples of
this divergence just to give you some intuition
for for what this means physically so i have
three examples i'm going to walk you through
and those three examples are pretty simple so
here's what i'm going to do let's write down
the vector field for example one so example
one we're going to have our vector field f
of x and y is going to equal x in the i direction
plus y in the j direction so this is i'm just
going to write these in lots of different ways so
you get comfortable going back and forth between
this kind of unit vector notation or this
column vector notation uh so similarly this
would be written as x and y okay that's what i
mean to have x in the i direction and y in the
j direction it's a vector like this and so what
that means is that at every point x and y there is
a vector of magnitude and direction given by this
vector here so let's let's actually draw this out
so if i look at the x y coordinates then what i
can do is at every point x and y i can draw the
vector given by this vector field so at the
x equals one y equals zero point right here
there is a vector pointing in the one zero
direction so like this similarly in the zero
one direction there's a vector pointing up in the
negative one direction pointing out and so on and
so forth at the one one point i have a vector that
is one one so going in the x and the y direction
and it looks kind of like this so you get this
idea that everything's kind of moving out away
from the origin in this and so our intuition is
that the divergence of this vector field should
be positive because things are diverging away
from from the origin so let's actually compute
this this divergence here so we'll compute
div of f the divergence of f is equal to
uh partial f1 partial x that's just one
plus partial f2 partial y that's also one
so this is like partial x partial x
plus partial y partial y equals 1 plus 1
equals 2. so what we say is that this flow has
a positive divergence or the flow is diverging
that's kind of how we would say it this flow is
diverging and another way to think about this
is that if i had a little blob of you know
a little patch of material here and this was
a fluid flow in the ocean this is a little oil
slick and this is the the fluid flow in the ocean
then if i if i integrate that patch of particles
forward in time i flow it along the fluid flow
that patch is going to get
bigger by a certain amount
and it's in fact going to get bigger you know
in an amount that's related to the divergence
okay so a positive divergence means that little
patches are locally going to get bigger or kind of
expand and a negative divergence would mean the
opposite patches are going to contract or shrink
okay so you can think of this like a little
point oil spill and things are going to
source out from that okay let's do another
example so the other example i want to do
is kind of the exact opposite case where we have
a converging or negative divergence vector field
so we'll have the same f x and y equals and
now in this case we're going to say it equals
minus x in the i direction minus y in the j
direction and so we've literally all we've done
is changed all of the arrows all of the directions
of these arrows so now my points are moving in
in a way that is kind of proportional to
x and y at those points and again if i'm
farther out if i'm at negative 2 negative 2 then
my point is moving in even faster and so that's
also important to draw that these are kind of
from farther away they actually accelerate in
okay good so let's again go through the motions
of computing this divergence i just want you
to get very comfortable doing these vector
operations so the divergence is just the dot
product of this partial derivative vector with
this vector field f1 f2 and so let's do that
the divergence of f in this case
is again partial minus x partial x
so partial minus x with respect to x
plus partial minus y with respect to y
and that equals negative 1 plus negative
1 equals negative 2. maybe i'll box these
okay and so in this case essentially if
we just change the direction of our vector
field so instead of everything kind of blowing out
things are sinking in i have a negative divergence
and we say that this flow is converging so this
one was diverging and this one is converging
okay or it's a compressible flow things are
compressing and again if i take my little
patch now i'm going to start with a patch kind
of out here i have a big patch and if i flow that
big patch forward in time it's going to shrink
by a factor that's related to this divergence
this this negative 2 here okay so that's really
really useful this kind of divergence being
positive means our volumes grow divergence
negative means our volumes contract
and for the last example i'm going to show you a
vector field that has divergence zero and we'll
see that the kind of volume of these patches stays
the same so that's the third example example 3
is a flow with divergence 0. maybe i'm giving away
the punch line so this vector field i think it's
going to be minus y in the i direction plus x in
the j direction so this one's a little different
than these in these vector fields the x component
was equal to x and the y component was equal to y
but here they're kind of switched so this
equals minus y x and now i'm going to draw
this vector field here so again if i want to
draw this vector field given by by f arrow i
literally just take test points and i evaluate
what is this vector at all of those test points
so at the one zero point when x is one and y
is zero this vector is zero one which points up
so right here my vector field is pointing up in
the zero one position when x is zero and y is one
this is a negative 1 0 vector so it's pointing in
the left direction negative 1 in the x direction
0 in the y direction and so on and so forth if i'm
here it's pointing down if i'm here it's pointing
to the right if i'm farther out it's twice as
big so i get this kind of thing going on here
it's a little hard to draw these if i'm at some
diagonal point here it's kind of moving diagonally
like this so that's what this flow flow
looks like and uh we'll compute the um
the divergence of this to confirm that it's
zero and then we'll drop our test patch and
see what happens to that test patch okay so the
divergence of f the divergence of f is equal to
partial f1 partial x so that is partial
negative y with respect to x plus partial f2
which is x with respect to y and now you know
partial y with respect to x is zero partial
x with respect to y is zero and so this vector
field has zero divergence it is divergence free
i'm going to write that down so this is called a
divergence divergence free vector field okay very
important type of a vector field and one of the
kind of intuitive pieces is that a divergence free
vector field is characterized entirely by rotation
so it's not sourcing or sinking it's only rotating
and so again if i take my little patch
here let's put a little patch right here
this patch doesn't get stretched or or shrinks it
just rotates around this flow literally just kind
of is a solid body rotation and it just after some
amount of time moves that patch so it stays the
same but rotates over. So this is a nice example
of a divergence free vector field; this one has
positive divergence; this one has negative
divergence; and this one is divergence free.
Okay good. So those are three
examples of the divergence.
There are a couple things I want to show you
here, because I think this is really useful:
when I have a vector field like this "f
arrow" you can think of these vector fields as
establishing a differential equation. So
this differential equation here, if I take
this "f bar" of x and y, let's just
rewrite this as a differential equation.
So what I can do is think of how a particle
will flow or move around in this vector field
and this is a very useful perspective in systems.
I can write d/dt of my point (x, y) equals
f bar of x and y, and in that case it equals this
vector field here. So in matrix notation it would
be [1 0; 0 1] times [x; y]^T. And normally we're
used to seeing this kind of linear system of
equations from differential equations, so that's
one way you can think of these vector fields:
these vector fields are essentially the right hand
side of a differential equation describing what
a particle would do in that vector field. So this
field of vectors, if I drop my little red particle
or pink particle here, I can integrate this
differential equation to find out where it goes.
And then here, of course, you see that the
solution is going to be x... maybe I'll just
write it down... here x and y at time t
are going to equal to e^t x_0, and e^t
y_0... and so you have this growth of these
initial conditions, they expand and they
accelerate away from that initial condition. Okay
good. And maybe what I'll do in a future lecture,
is I'll relate this divergence quantity
to the exponential expansion of particles,
because there's a rigorous way of connecting this
divergence quantity and the exponential expansion
rate of particles in these vector fields. Okay
let's recap. So we're talking about the divergence
which is the dot product of my 'del' or
'nabla' operator with a vector-valued function
and again when I take the dot product of two
vectors I get a scalar, so the divergence of
a vector-valued function is a scalar function
it's just a scalar in this case it was a constant
because my vector field was linear
if i made this an x squared here
then this would be uh partial minus x squared
partial x would be minus two x minus one
and the divergence would actually be a function of
x so my but it's still a scalar function it's not
a vector function it's a scalar function of x and
y and it can quantify locally in my vector field
is my particle expanding is it contracting or
is it just doing kind of a solid body rotation
with divergence free now the last
last last thing i want to show you
is what happens if i take a scalar function so
remember i can take the gradient of a scalar
function so i can take my regular old scalar
function f and if i take the gradient of it now
i have a vector valued function so this would be
a vector function partial f1 partial x partial f2
partial x and so what if i take the divergence
of the gradient so if i take the divergence of
the gradient of a function f then essentially what
this equals is partial partial x partial partial y
dot product with partial f uh sorry this is just f
because this is a scalar i really botched this up
pardon me this is partial f partial x and partial
f partial y because f is a scalar and so this is
this is the gradient partial of partial x partial
f partial y and if i compute this dot product
remember the dot product of of two vectors is
easy you just take the product of the first two
uh you know the the first components of
both of them plus the product of the second
components of both of them and now what i
have is the second partial derivative of f
with respect to x squared plus the second
partial derivative of f with respect to y
squared so this is cool this is the sum of second
partial derivatives of f with respect to x and y
and so the divergence of the gradient of a
scalar function f is this quantity this is
called the laplacian of f this is uh del squared
of f and it's also a scalar value the laplacian
and this is going to come up all over the
place this is one of the most important linear
differential operators in all of physics this is
how we're going to study electrostatic potentials
uh incompressible irrotational fluid flows this
is an extremely extremely important quantity
i'll tell you all about later kind of how to work
partial differential equations using this operator
but again i just want you to be very comfortable
that you can use these building blocks together
if i have a scalar function i can compute its
gradient to get a vector function if i then take
that vector valued function i can compute the
divergence of it to get another scalar valued
function and that scalar valued function the div
of the grad of f is called the laplacian and it's
a very very useful uh useful quantity okay so i
hope you're finding this interesting we're about
to so i'll tell you about curl next time kind
of you know we'll actually look at this example
down here where this field is divergence free but
it's rotating so we'll compute the curl next time
then we're going to start talking about
some kind of identities like gauss's theorem
stokes's theorem and how you can use these
building blocks to build partial differential
equations for example laplace's equation what
happens if i say del squared f equals zero
this is a partial differential equation it's a
differential equation with partial derivatives
and the properties of f f will be a very very
special function if it satisfies this partial
differential equation so that's all coming
up soon stay tuned and you're going to know
you know tons about pdes and vector
calculus in a few more lectures thank you